>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IF YOU TUNED IN TO SEE THE
HEARING IN THE SENATE ARMED
SERVICES' COMMITTEE TODAY, AND
IF YOU DIDN'T, HE MISSED OUT,
BUT IF HE DID, YOU MAY HAVE BEEN
A LITTLE SURPRISED TO SEE
MARK MILLEY SITTING THERE.
YOU REMEMBER MILLIE.
HE'S THE FLESHY HOOD EYED MAN,
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS OF
STAFF.
HE IS ALSO A NATIONAL DISGRACE,
IS A LIVING INSULT TO THE
MILITARY OVERSEAS.
THAT'S NOT AN INSULT, IT'S
OBJECTIVELY TRUE.
I GET YET SOMEHOW DESPITE THE
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE THAT
MARK MILLEY IS DISHONEST,
INCOMPETENT, PARTISAN,
DISHONORABLE, MARK MILLEY STILL
HAS A HIGHLY PROMINENT JOB,
THAT'S THE AMAZING THING.
AND NOT ONLY IS MARK MILLEY
STILL EMPLOYED AT THE VERY
HIGHEST LEVEL, HE IS STILL LYING
AND DOING SO WITH HIS
CHARACTERISTIC RELISH AND
ENTHUSIASM.
TODAY, FOR EXAMPLE, WITH AN
ENTIRELY STRAIGHT FACE,
MARK MILLEY DELIVERED AN
IMPASSIONED LECTURE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF CIVILIAN CONTROL
OF THE MILITARY.
"THIS COUNTRY DOESN'T WANT
GENERALS FIGURING OUT WHAT
ORDERS WE ARE GOING TO ACCEPT OR
DO OR NOT, THAT'S NOT OUR JOB."
OH, REALLY?
IS THAT SO, MARK MILLEY?
ISN'T THIS THE SAME MARK MILLEY
WHO ONCE ILLEGALLY SEIZED
PERSONAL CONTROL OF OUR
COUNTRY'S NUCLEAR ARSENAL?
AND THEN WHEN THAT WASN'T
SUFFICIENT, PROMISED TO TIP OFF
THE GOVERNOR OF CHINA ABOUT
FUTURE MILITARY OPERATIONS AND
DID ALL OF THIS WHO DIDN'T LIKE
HIS BOSS WHO UNLIKE HIM WAS,
YES, CIVILIAN ELECTED BY VOTERS.
THAT'S THE VERY SAME
MARK MILLEY, THE ONE LECTURING
ABOUT THE MILITARY.
IT WAS ALL PRETTY AMUSING IN A
DARK WAY, BUT HE DID MAKE YOU
WONDER, WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
WHY IS MARK MILLEY SAYING
SOMETHING SO OBVIOUSLY
PREPOSTEROUS?
EXPECT TO BE HELPING HIM IN SOME
WAY.
WHEN DID NEED IT WAS HELPING
HIM.
WHAT YOU WATCH IN THE SENATE
HEARING TODAY WAS PURE BLAME
SHIFTING.
JOE BIDEN'S FOREIGN POLICY IS A
LEGITIMATE DISASTER, NOBODY
DISPUTES THAT, BUT MARK MILLEY
WANTS YOU TO KNOW THAT NONE OF
IT IS HIS FAULT.
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE WANTS YOU
TO KNOW THAT TOO.
SO DOES THE HEAD OF CENTRAL
COMMAND, GENERAL McKENZIE.
ALL THREE OF THEM WANT TO MAKE
IT CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT THE
SCENERY DULL MAXING OUT ON THE
WHITE HOUSE DID THIS, IT'S HIS
FAULT, NOT THEIRS.
IT WAS JOE BIDEN, THEY TOLD US
TODAY, WHO FORCED AMERICAN
TROOPS TO LEAVE AFGHANISTAN
BEFORE WE EVACUATED ALL AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
AND BECAUSE THE PENTAGON
REFLEXIVELY IN EVERY CASE
FOLLOWS EVERY ORDER UP TO THE
LETTER FROM THE SITTING
PRESIDENT, THEY HAD NO CHOICE
BUT TO OBEY THESE CRAZY
DECISIONS.
WATCH THEM EXPLAIN.
>> GENERAL MILLEY, IT'S YOUR
TESTIMONY THAT YOU RECOMMENDED
2500 TROOPS APPROXIMATELY STAY
IN AFGHANISTAN?
>> YES, MY ASSESSMENT WAS BACK
IN THE FALL OF APOSTOLATE 20 AND
REMAINED CONSISTENTLY THROUGHOUT
THAT WE SHOULD KEEP A STEADY --
COULD BOUNCE UP TO 3500, MAYBE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> GENERAL McKENZIE, DO YOU
SHARE THAT ASSESSMENT?
>> SENATOR, I DO SHARE THAT
ASSESSMENT.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN LAST MONTH IN
AN INTERVIEW WITH GEORGE TOUGH
ANNAPOLIS SAID NO MILITARY
LEADER ADVISED HIM TO LEAVE A
SMALL TROOP PRESENCE IN
AFGHANISTAN.
DID THESE OFFICER AND GENERAL
MILLER'S RECOMMENDATION GET TO
THE PRESIDENT PERSONALLY?
>> THEIR INPUT WAS RECEIVED BY
THE PRESIDENT AND CONSIDERED BY
THE PRESIDENT FOR SURE.
IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY
SPECIFICALLY RECOMMENDED,
SENATOR, AS THEY JUST SAID, THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO PROVIDE WHAT
THEY RECOMMENDED IN THE
CONFERENCE.
>> Tucker: YOU FOLLOWING THIS?
WHEELS OFFICIALLY COMING OFF BUT
WHAT SLEAZE BALLS THESE GUYS
ARE.
WE TOLD JOE BIDEN TO KEEP 2500
TROOPS IN THE COUNTRY, WE
DEMANDED IT.
ON THE OTHER HAND, BECAUSE WE
ARE BOUND BY THE ANCIENT AND
SACRED RULES OF CONFIDENTIALITY,
WE CAN'T REALLY TELL YOU WHAT WE
TOLD THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE THAT
WOULD BE WRONG.
[CACKLES]
THESE PEOPLE SO THOROUGHLY
DESERVE EACH OTHER.
IT IS WONDERFUL TO SEE THEM RENT
ONE ANOTHER OUT, WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT THEY PROCEEDED TO
DO FOR THE ENTIRETY OF TODAY'S
HEARING.
WATCH GENERAL McKENZIE
EXPLAINED THAT DESPITE THE FACT
THAT HE PERSONALLY OVERSAW THE
DISASTER IN AFGHANISTAN,
ACTUALLY HE HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH IT, IT WAS ALL DEMENTED
GRANDPA PULLING THE STRINGS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> I WON'T SHARE MY PERSONAL
RECOGNITION TO THE PRESIDENT BUT
I WILL GIVE YOU MY HONEST
OPINION, AND MY HONEST OPINION
AND VIEW SHAPED MY
RECOMMENDATION.
I RECOMMENDED THAT WE MAINTAIN
2,500 TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN, AND
I ALSO RECOMMENDED EARLIER IN
THE FALL OF 2020 THAT WE
MAINTAIN 4,500 AT THAT TIME.
THOSE ARE MY PERSONAL VIEWS.
I ALSO HAVE A VIEW THAT THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THOSE FORCES WOULD
LEAD INEVITABLY TO THE COLLAPSE
OF THE AFGHAN MILITARY FORCES
AND EVENTUALLY THE AFGHAN
GOVERNMENT.
>> Tucker: WHAT A DIRT BALL
THAT GUY IS EMMA DID YOU HEAR
THAT?
I CAN'T SHARE A CONDITION, BUT
HERE WAS MY RECOMMENDATION.
[CACKLES]
TAKE THOSE METALS OFF YOU DON'T
DESERVE THEM.
UNTIL TODAY, MANY OF THEM HAVE
BEEN UNDERMINING BIDEN
INDIRECTLY.
FAR BE IT FOR US TO DEFEND
JOE BIDEN, WHO DESERVES NO
DEFENSE BUT IT IS A DEFENSE OF
THE AMERICAN SYSTEM, WHICH WORKS
WELL WHEN CIVILIANS CONTROL THE
MILITARY.
UP UNTIL TODAY, THEY HAVE BEEN
LEAKING BIDEN'S PHONE CALLS FOR
EXAM WILL, THE PRESIDENT OF
AFGHANISTAN, THAT'S ILLEGAL, BUT
THEY DID IT ANYWAY.
THEY'VE BEEN GIVING NASTY
BACKGROUND QUOTES TO THE
STENOGRAPHERS AND NBC NEWS.
TODAY WAS DIFFERENT, TODAY'S
PERFORMANCE TOOK PLACE IN
PUBLIC.
IT WAS ON THE RECORD AND IT WAS
UNDER OATH, AND IN THAT
PERFORMANCE, THEY DIRECTLY
CONTRADICTED THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
AS A REMINDER, HERE'S WHAT
JOE BIDEN WAS SAYING JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO ON ABC.
YOUR TOP MILITARY ADVISORS
WARNED AGAINST, THEY WANTED YOU
TO KEEP ABOUT 2500 TROOPS.
>> President Biden: NO THEY
DIDN'T, IT WAS SPLIT.
THAT WASN'T TRUE.
>> THEY DIDN'T TELL YOU THEY
WANTED TROOPS TO STAY?
>> President Biden: NO, NOT IN
TERMS OF WHETHER WE WERE GOING
TO GET OUT IN A TIME FRAME ALL
TROOPS.
THEY DIDN'T ARGUE AGAINST THAT.
>> SO NO ONE TOLD -- OR MILITARY
ADVISORS DID NOT TELL YOU KNOW,
WE SHOULD KEEP 2500 TROOPS, IT'S
BEEN A STABLE SITUATION FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS, WE CAN DO
THAT, WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO
THAT?
>> President Biden: NO, NO ONE
SAID THAT TO ME THAT I CAN
RECALL.
>> Tucker: OH, IT'S NOT A
DEFENSE OF ANY OF THEM, THEY ARE
ALL SO AWFUL AND UNDESERVING OF
LEADING THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE IN CHARGE OF
THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S TOO GOOD A COUNTRY FOR
PEOPLE LIKE THIS.
SO YOU ALREADY HAVE THE GENERALS
CLAIMING THEY TOLD BIDEN THE
AFGHAN WITHDRAWAL WOULD BE A
TOTAL DISASTER.
BIDEN, JUST IN THE TAPE HE SAW
SAID THEY DID NOT TELL HIM THAT.
THE QUESTION IS WAS LANGFORD
SOMEONE IS LYING, JOE BIDEN
DOESN'T ALWAYS LINE, HE DOESN'T
REMEMBER ANYTHING, HE DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT HE HAD FOR LUNCH.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW FOR SURE AND
THIS IS THE POINT OF TODAY'S
HEARING END OF THE POINT THAT
MATTERS GOING FORWARD.
NO ONE IN THE PENTAGON'S
LEADERSHIP WILL EVER BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS, THE LATEST
IN A VERY LONG STRING OF
COLOSSAL SCRUBS THAT HAVE
DRAMATICALLY REDUCED AMERICAN
POWER AND PRESTIGE AROUND THE
WORLD, AND GOTTEN A TON OF
PEOPLE KILLED.
NO ONE.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
LET'S SAY YOU WORKED IN A
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT AND WENDY
HAD TOO MANY BEERS ON YOUR LUNCH
BREAK AND HE FELL ASLEEP IN THE
REACTOR MELTED DOWN AND
THOUSANDS DIED, AND THEN YOU GOT
A MASSIVE RAISE.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE.
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
JUST PASSED $776 BILLION DEFENSE
BUDGET.
HOW BIG IS THAT?
WELL, IT'S FULLY $24 BILLION
MORE THAN EVEN THE WHITE HOUSE
REQUESTED.
NONE OF US, CONGRESS JUST THREW
IN A LITTLE EXTRA FOR A JOB WELL
DONE, A BONUS FOR THE GENERALS
WHO LEFT $80 BILLION WORTH OF
AMERICAN MILITARY EQUIPMENT FOR
THE TALIBAN TO USE.
GOOD WORK, GUYS!
SO IT'S OFFICIAL NOW.
NO ONE WILL EVER BE PUNISHED FOR
ANY OF IT.
NOT FOR ABANDONING THE AIR BASE,
THAT WAS IDIOTIC, EVERYONE KNEW
IT, EVER THEY DID IT ANYWAY.
NOT FOR LEAVING AMERICAN
CITIZENS BEHIND AS THEY FLED,
NOT FOR LEAVING OUR TROOPS
EXPOSED TO THE ATTACK THAT
KILLED 13 YOUNG AMERICAN
SERVICEMAN, NOT FOR THE DRONE
STRIKE THAT GLOW OF CHILDREN,
THE ONE THEY LIED ABOUT FOR
WEEKS.
THE PEOPLE WHO DID THESE THINGS
ARE IN GREAT SHAPE TONIGHT.
THEY WILL RETIRE EXACTLY WHEN
THEY FEEL LIKE RETIREMENT, AT
WHICH POINT THEY WILL GET FULL
BENEFITS AND JOBS AT LOCKHEED.
THAT'S HOW OUR SYSTEM NO WORKS.
IT'S VERY, VERY FRUSTRATING.
NOT BECAUSE RECRIMINATION IS
GOOD, BUT BECAUSE IN ORDER TO
FUNCTION, A SYSTEM TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND AS OF TONIGHT, THERE'S ONLY
ONE MAN IN THE ENTIRE U.S.
GOVERNMENT WHO IS BEING PUNISHED
FOR THE FAILURE, THE
CATASTROPHIC FAILURE IN
AFGHANISTAN, JUST ONE MAN.
HE IS THE LIEUTENANT COLONEL IN
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS.
HE'S AN HONORABLE AND HONEST
MAN.
HE IS ALSO BLAMELESS.
HE HAD NO ROLE IN ANY OF THESE
DECISIONS.
WHAT WAS HIS CRIME?
'S CRIME WAS CRITICIZING THOSE
DECISIONS.
IN AUGUST HE POSTED THIS VIDEO
ON THE INTERNET.
>> IF A BATTALION COMMANDER HAS
THE SIMPLEST COMPLAINT, BOOM,
FIRE, WE HAVE A SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE THAT TESTIFIED TO
CONGRESS IN MAY THAT THE AFGHAN
NATIONAL SECURITY FORCE COULD
WITHSTAND THE TALIBAN ADVANCE.
WE HAVE CHAIRMAN ENJOYED CHEATS
WHO COME OUT AS A MEMBER THAT
WAS BOTH TO ADVISE THE MILITARY
POLICY, WE HAVE A MARINE
COMBATANT COMMANDER, ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE ARE SUPPOSED TO
ADVISE AND I'M NOT SAYING WE GOT
TO BE IN AFGHANISTAN FOREVER,
BUT I AM SAYING DID ANY OF YOU
THROW YOUR RANK ON THE TABLE AND
SAY HEY, IT'S A BAD IDEA TO
EVACUATE BAGRAM AIRFIELD, THE
STRATEGIC AIRBASE, BEFORE WE
EVACUATE EVERYONE?
>> Tucker: THAT'S AN HONORABLE
IN USE ON THE SCREEN.
THAT'S A MAN WHO'S IN IT FOR THE
RIGHT REASONS, HE CARES ABOUT
THE COUNTRY AND WANTS TO DEFEND
IT.
THERE'S A MAN WHO BELIEVED IN
HIS SUPERIORS, WHO IS NOT
CYNICAL, WHO IS GENUINELY
CONFUSED BY HIS SUPERIORS'
UNWILLINGNESS TO ADMIT THEIR OWN
ERROR.
HIS CONFUSION COMES FROM
DECENCY.
AND ALL MOST IMMEDIATELY HIS
SUPERIORS REACTED TO THAT VIDEO.
THEY DIDN'T APOLOGIZE FOR THE
DISASTER, DIDN'T EXPLAIN WHY
THEY DID WITH THE DEAD, THEY
PUNISHED HIM.
THEY RELIEVED HIM OF HIS COMMAND
AND THEY TOLD HIM TO SHUT UP AND
STOP TALKING.
BUT HE DIDN'T STOP TALKING.
HERE'S HOW HE RESPONDED.
>> TO RECAP MY POSITION IN THE
FALL OUT OF AFGHANISTAN, I
DEMANDED ACCOUNT ABILITY FOR MY
SENIOR LEADERS AT I SAY AGAIN
THAT I UNDERSTOOD THAT I MIGHT
LOSE MY RETIREMENT AND MY FAMILY
STABILITY.
AS IT HAS PLAYED OUT, I HAVE IN
FACT LOST ALL THREE OF THOSE
THINGS.
WHAT I DO IT AGAIN?
I DON'T KNOW.
MY NAME IS LIEUTENANT COLONEL
STUART SCHELLER AND I WAS THE
ONLY OFFICER IN THE ENTIRE
AMERICAN COALITION FIRED IN THE
DEBACLE OF THE AFGHAN FOLLOW.
I ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I SHOULD HAVE
BEEN FIRED.
HOWEVER, THE HYPOCRISY OF THE
GENERAL OFFICERS WHO ARE NOT
BEING HELD TO THE SAME STANDARD
IS A MICROCOSM FOR THE ENTIRE
PROBLEM THAT IS GOING TO BRING
DOWN THE GREAT INSTITUTIONS OF
THIS REPUBLIC THAT WE LOVE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE MAN YOU
WANT SERVING IN YOUR OFFICER
CORPS IN A SERIOUS COUNTRY, A
PERSON WHO TAKES HIS JOB
SERIOUSLY, IS PATRIOTIC, WHO IS
HONEST, WHO DEMANDS ACCOUNT
ABILITY.
AND BEFORE YOU SAY IT'S THE
MILITARY, THEY DON'T HAVE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH, YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO GIVE A POLITICAL
STATEMENT, TWO POINTS, ONE, THAT
WAS NOT UP POLITICALLY EXPLICIT
STATEMENT.
ENDLESS NUMBER OF OPENLY
PARTISAN STATEMENTS OF THE
LEADERS OF THE PENTAGON.
MARK MILLEY WAS OPENLY THRILLED
BY THE ELECTION OF JOE BIDEN.
WAS HE PUNISHED FOR THAT?
NO, HE WAS ELEVATED IN CONGRESS
AGAIN JUST REWARDED HIM IN THE
ENTIRE LEADERSHIP OF THE U.S.
MILITARY WITH 24 EXTRA BILLION
DOLLARS.
BUT STUART SCHELLER FOR TELLING
THE TRUTH?
WELL, HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED TO
HIM.
MILITARY BRASS FOREST HIM TO
UNDERGO A PSYCHOLOGICAL
EVALUATION BECAUSE ONLY A CRAZY
PERSON WOULD ASK FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY AFTER THE
DISASTER IN AFGHANISTAN.
AND THEN WHEN HE WOULDN'T ADMIT
HE WAS CRAZY, THEY THREW HIM IN
PRISON, IN JAIL, WHERE HE SITS
TONIGHT.
HIS FATHER JUST RELEASED THIS
STATEMENT EXPLAIN HIS SON IS NOW
BEHIND BARS WITH VIOLENT
CRIMINALS.
HOW LONG IS HE THERE?
HE'S THERE INDEFINITELY.
THIS IS HAPPENING TO MIGHT OR
MIGHT TONIGHT AMERICA.
"ALL OUR SON DID WAS ASK THE
QUESTION THAT EVERYONE WAS
ASKING THEMSELVES THAT THEY WERE
TOO SCARED TO SPEAK OUT LOUD, IT
WAS ASKING FOR ACCOUNT ABILITY.
I THINK EVEN ASKED FOR A APOLOGY
THAT WE MADE MISTAKES BUT THEY
COULDN'T DO THAT, WHICH WAS
MIND-BLOWING, THEY HAD A GAG
ORDER ON HIM AND ASK HIM TO
SPEAK.
HE DID SPEAK AND THEY
INCARCERATED HIM VERY THEY DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH THEM."
ONE OF T